♪
>> Lawrence: TODAY JOE BIDEN MET
WITH THE FAMILY OF GEORGE FLOYD
PRIVATELY AT THE WHITE HOUSE ON
THE ONE YEAR ANNIVERSARY OF HIS
DEATH.
MEANWHILE ON FLOYD SQUARE.
>> GOT TO BE CAREFUL WITH SOME
GUNSHOTS.
[GUNFIRE]
>> SOUND LIKE GUNSHOTS.
[SHOUTING]
>> SEEM TO BE GUNSHOTS.
>> GET DONE!
DOWN!
>> Lawrence: SOUNDS LIKE
GUNSHOTS BECAUSE IT IS GUNSHOTS.
MORE THAN TWO DOZEN SHOTS FIRED
IN BROAD DAYLIGHT JUST FEET FROM
THE MEMORIAL FOR GEORGE FLOYD.
REPORTERS AND BYSTANDERS CAUGHT
ON CAMERA RUNNING FOR THEIR
LIVES.
PHOTO OP. CONVERSATION BRAZEN
GUNFIRE EMPTY GESTURES IN
AMERICAN CARNAGE.
THE CONTRAST IS JARRING BUT
EMBLEMATIC OF WHERE WE ARE IN
AMERICA RIGHT NOW.
THE PUBLIC VIRTUE SIGNAL
SOMETHING MORE IMPORTANT THAN
TAKING ACTION.
WE HAVE A PRESIDENT IN THE WHITE
HOUSE WHO PROMISED TO FIGHT FOR
THE SOUL OF AMERICA AND HEAL THE
DEEP WOUNDS ACROSS THIS COUNTRY.
TODAY 143 DAYS SINCE BIDEN TOOK
OFFICE AND A YEAR AFTER GEORGE
FLOYD'S DEATH, WHERE ARE WE NOW?
LET'S LOOK AT THE CITY OF
MINNEAPOLIS.
HAVE THE DEMOCRATS MADE LIFE
THERE ANY BETTER THAN A YEAR
SINCE GEORGE FLOYD WAS KILLED?
LET'S CHECK?
THEY DEFUNDED THE POLICE AND
WATCHED CRIME SKYROCKET.
HOMICIDES ARE UP 112%.
RAPES UP 29%.
AGGRAVATED ASSAULT UP 63%.
THINGS HAVE GOTTEN SO BAD THAT
THEY HAVE TO SCRAMBLE TO REFUND
THE POLICE JUST MONTHS AFTER
DEFUNDING IT JOE BIDEN URGED
CONGRESS TO PASS THE GEORGE
FLOYD POLICE REFORM ACT BY
TODAY.
SO WHERE'S THE BILL?
WHERE IS THE URGENCY TO GET THIS
DEAL DONE?
OR DID THE DEMOCRATS THINK THAT
THEIR WORK WAS OVER WHEN THEY
THREW ON THE CLOTH AND TOOK A
KNEE?
LET'S BE HONEST FOR A MINUTE, IF
THE DEMOCRATS MANAGED TO SOLVE
AMERICA'S POLICING PROBLEM,
THERE WOULD STILL BE MAJOR
SYSTEMIC ISSUES FACING BLACK
AMERICA THAT NEEDS ADDRESSING.
JOBS, EDUCATION CRISIS.
AND FAITH IN LEADERSHIP.
THESE ARE ISSUES THAT THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT CAN'T BEGIN
TO SOLVE.
THEY NEED TO BE FIXED ON THE
LOCAL LEVEL.
THEY FOR THIS.
SO WHO IS GOING TO STEP UP?
I KNOW SOMEONE.
HOW ABOUT KING RANDLE, A
21-YEAR-OLD FOUNDER OF X FOR
BOYS, A MARINE VETERAN AND HE
JOINS ME RIGHT NOW.
SO, KING, WHAT NEEDS TO HAPPEN
TO SOLVE THIS PROBLEM?
>> I DEFINITELY THINK ALL OF
US -- WELL, ALL OF US SHOULD
HOLD OUR LEADERS ACCOUNTABLE IN
THEIR DIFFERENT POSITIONS WHERE
THEY ARE IN EACH OF THINK
CITIES.
I FEEL LIKE WATCHING MEDIA AND
LOOKING ON SOCIAL MEDIA ET
CETERA IS KIND OF TAKING US
BACKWARDS BECAUSE WE ARE NOT
HOLDING OUR LEADERS ACCOUNTABLE.
WE ARE POINTING FINGERS YOU KNOW
AT EVERYONE EXCEPT OUR LEADERS
AND WE WON'T HOLD THEM
RESPONSIBLE FOR WHAT'S GOING ON
IN OUR COMMUNITIES.
>> Lawrence: KING, I HAVE BEEN
SO PROUD OF YOUR TRAJECTORY
BECAUSE YOU ARE OUT THERE
FIGHTING FOR THE COMMUNITY EVERY
SINGLE DAY.
YOU JUST BOUGHT SOME LAND.
YOU ARE HELPING RAISE YOUNG MEN
UP.
TEACHING THEM ABOUT FIREARMS.
YOU ARE EDUCATING THEM.
TELL US ABOUT WHAT YOU DO EVERY
DAY.
>> WELL, I WORK WITH CHILDREN.
I HAVE BEEN WORKING WITH THEM
FOR TWO YEARS NOW.
I ACTUALLY STARTED TAKING
TEMPORARY CUSTODY OF CHILDREN IN
MY HOME.
I WORK WITH CHILDREN THAT HAVE
BEEN MOLESTED.
THEY HAVE BEEN SEXUALLY ABUSED.
THAT HAVE BEEN STARVED AT HOME,
ET.
THESE CHILDREN DON'T HAVE
ANYWHERE TO SLEEP.
I TAKE THEM INTO MY HOME AND I
MAKE THINGS HAPPEN.
WE ARE IN THE PROCESS OF OPENING
A SCHOOL FOR THESE CHILDREN IN
THE CITY OF ALBANY, WE ARE
ACTUALLY PURCHASING THE SCHOOL
FROM MY LOCAL SCHOOL SYSTEM AND
WE HAVE BEEN WORKING ON A DEAL
FOR SEVEN MONTHS WITH OUR LOCAL
SCHOOL SYSTEM BUT THEY HAVE BEEN
GIVING US PUSHBACK IN TRYING TO
DO THINGS THAT ARE BLATANTLY
COUNTER REPUBLICAN TIA AS TO
WHAT WE ARE TRYING TO DO.
WE ARE TRYING TO OPEN OUR OWN
PRIVATE SCHOOL IN THE CITY OF
ALBANY YET OUR SCHOOL BOARD
LEADERSHIP DOESN'T WANT THOSE
THINGS TO HAPPEN.
>> Lawrence: SO THE SCHOOL BOARD
LEADERS, IF YOU ARE TRYING TO
HELP KIDS, YOU HAVE A PROVEN
TRACK RECORD.
THE KIDS LOVE YOU, LOOK AT THEM.
THIS IS BLACK AMERICA RIGHT HERE
TELL ME WHAT THEY'RE DOING
EXACTLY TO TRY TO BLOCK YOU FROM
HELPING THESE KIDS?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
WELL, WE ARE ACTUALLY TRYING TO
PURCHASE THE SCHOOL FROM THEM
THAT WAS UP FOR DEMOLITION.
MIND YOU, I SAID THE SCHOOL WAS
UP FOR DEMOLITION AND THEY GAVE
US A CONTRACT BACK -- EXCUSE ME
A PURCHASE SALE AGREEMENT THAT
SAY THEY WANT HALF A MILLION
DOLLARS.
OVER HALF A MILLION DOLLARS FOR
THIS SCHOOL UP FOR DEMOLITION.
I WASN'T REALLY EVEN TOO UPSET
ABOUT THAT UNTIL I GOT THE
CONTRACT STIPULATIONS.
I HAVENER SEEN A PURCHASE SALE
AGREEMENT WHERE THE SELLER TELLS
A BUYER WHAT THEY CAN AND CAN'T
DO WITH A BUILDING.
THEY PUT IN THE CONTRACT AND
SAID THAT THE DEED OF CONVEYANCE
SHALL CONTAIN A YOUTH
RESTRICTION THAT WE CANNOT USE
THE SCHOOL THAT WE'RE PURCHASING
TO OPEN A PRIVATE OR A CHARTER
SCHOOL UNLESS THE COUNTY SCHOOL
SYSTEM IS PROVIDING EDUCATIONAL
SERVICES.
MEANING THEY WOULD GET FUNDING
FOR THE STUDENTS COME TO OUR
SCHOOLS AND WE CAN'T TEACH WHAT
WE WANT TO TEACH.
WE HAVE TO LET -- PAYING THEM TO
HANDCUFF US TO THEM.
I FIND THAT ABSOLUTELY ABSURD
HOW YOU ARE TRYING TO DO THAT TO
SOME CHILDREN AND MAKE ME SELL
MY CHILDREN OUT FOR A DOLLAR.
ABSOLUTELY NOT.
I BELIEVE THE TAXPAYERS WANT
THIS SCHOOL TO BE DONATED TO US.
AND THE SCHOOL SUPERINTENDENT
TOLD OUR COMMUNITY ONLY WAY THEY
COULD DONATE IF THE SCHOOL WOULD
BE PUBLIC BENEFIT FOR THE
COMMUNITY AND CLEARLY OUR SCHOOL
AND OUR TRACK RECORD FOR THE X
BOYS ARE PROVING OF PROVEN.
WE HAVE BEEN RUNNING FOR TWO
YEARS.
86% READING COMPREHENSION RATE.
OUR SUPERINTENDENT KNOWS WE HAVE
CHILDREN IN THE JUVENILE SYSTEM
WAITING ON THIS SCHOOL TO BE
OPEN.
WE HAVE CHILDREN THAT ARE IN
FOSTER HOMES AND GROUP HOMES
WAITING FOR THIS SCHOOL TO BE
OPEN.
WE HAVE MANY PARENTS WAITING FOR
THIS SCHOOL TO BE OPEN.
I HAVE BEEN STALLING THESE
PARENTS FOR SEVEN MONTHS THEY
SAY THEY ARE SO BUSY THEY CAN'T
GET THIS DEAL DONE.
I FIND IT ABSOLUTELY ABSURD I
HAVE TO KEEP TELLING THESE
CHILDREN TO WAIT, TO WAIT, TO
WAIT.
I DECIDED I WAS GOING TO CANCEL
THOSE NEGOTIATIONS WITH THEM
BECAUSE I HAVE TO GET THREE
PHONE CALLS AFTER WE HAD A
MEETING WITH OUR SCHOOL
SUPERINTENDENT THAT SAID
ALLEGEDLY THAT HE SAID THAT WE
WERE A COMPETITION THAT HE
DIDN'T WANT TO DONATE.
>> Lawrence: THERE IT IS RIGHT
THERE.
KING, IS THAT THE REASON WHY
THEY ARE DOING THIS?
THEY DON'T WANT ANY COMPETITION.
MEANWHILE THE SYSTEM IS FAILING
OUR KIDS.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
>> THERE NEEDS TO BE
ACCOUNTABILITY THERE.
WE SEE IT ALL ACROSS THE COUNTRY
WHERE YOU PUT THESE KIDS, GIVE
THEM A CHOICE.
THEY PERFORM IN CHARTER SCHOOLS.
YOU CANNOT SELL A BAG OF SPOILED
GOODS JUST BECAUSE THEY ARE POOR
AND BECAUSE THEY LIVE IN A
DIFFERENT NEIGHBORHOOD THAT THEY
CAN'T BE EDUCATED.
WE KNOW THAT'S NOT TRUE.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
AND I FIND IT EITHER VERY
DISHEARTENING.
I HAVE BEEN PRAISING THEM ON
DIFFERENT MEDIA OUTLETS BECAUSE
I WAS ASSUMING THEY WERE TRYING
TO WORK WITH US, ET CETERA.
THE BLATANT DISREGARD FOR OUR
STUDENTS THINKING THIS IS A
GAME.
COMPETITION IS A GAME TO ME.
CHILDREN DYING AND LOOK AT
COMPETITION.
WE ARE NOT TRYING TO GET
CHILDREN FROM THEIR SCHOOL
SYSTEM CHILDREN FROM THE
JUDICIAL SYSTEM CHILDREN FROM
THE STREETS AND NOT ENROLLED IN
YOUR SCHOOLS.
WE MADE IT CLEAR WE WANT TO BE A
PARTNER WITH THE COUNTY SCHOOL
SYSTEM YET THEY GIVE US A
CONTRACT THAT THEY SAY WAS IN
GOOD FAITH AND A PROPOSAL THAT
WE SENT YOU THAT WE WERE TRYING
TO OPEN OUR OWN SCHOOL YET TO
TELL US WE CAN'T OPEN OUR OWN
SCHOOL FROM A BUILDING THAT WE
ARE PURCHASE FOR HALF A MILLION
DOLLARS THAT WAS UP FOR
DEMOLITION.
>> Lawrence: KING, WE ARE NOT
DONE WITH THIS STORY THIS
AUDIENCE WILL CONTINUE TO
SUPPORT YOU.
WE FIRST INTRODUCED YOU ON "FOX
& FRIENDS."
AND WE WILL CONTINUE TO SUPPORT
YOU BECAUSE THIS IS WHAT THE
COUNTRY NEEDS.
YOU ARE OUT THERE DOING THE WORK
AND WE ARE SO PROUD OF YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR COMING ON
THE PROGRAM.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH.
MAKE I